kind of relaxed now you know okay we're
married this is what we wanted finally
we did it and so i feel less pressure
only i think only
me telling my parents that we are
married
don't tell them and we'll just go
live our life in a different state then
i'm in very tough spot
a lot of people know that we are married
if my parents comes to know uh through
someone else they might never talk to me
at work in and i don't want that to
happen
i cannot live a happy life without my
parents because in india uh parents and
kids relationship is very strong and
important
so i'm very nervous
i think it's gonna hurt our happiness i
think it's gonna cause problems for us
i cannot hide it because if somebody
else will go and tell them they feel
betrayed
it's your life
just think about how happy we've been
this whole time
i don't want to spoil this happiness
but the thing is now it's too late i
already
invited them
they are coming
tomorrow to our old house
am i meeting them
i would love that if you join us oh my
god this is gonna be a repeat of the
other time they came to our house except
this time i think it'll be worse
he didn't come and talk to me about this
it just was something that he did i feel
like i got i'm tricked into this
what the hell then why did we leave the
house that was my whole point let's be
comfortable and safe and i don't have to
worry about any of this drama going
on and now here we go
see
we get married we're happy and still we
can't be happy
[Music]
you